after using and testing the 15-inch
MacBook Air for over a month I have to
say that it is one of my favorite
laptops ever so why in the world is
Apple having such a hard time selling
them with volumes being half of what
they expected well in this long-term
Real World review I'm gonna focus on
five killer features of the 15-inch
MacBook Air along with three major
downsides that is not helping apple with
this machine and what went wrong
starting out with the design this thing
is simple it is elegant and it is
extremely thin and lightweight I
compared it to the previous Intel
MacBook Pro with a large screen and it's
a lot lighter thinner it's better in
every way less expensive if you compare
msrps especially with inflation and it
is way faster we don't have speaker
girls on the sides and the ports are a
bit limited but this is the laptop that
so many people were asking for you have
a screen size that is not too small like
the 13 inch and not too large like a 16
inch which requires extra bulk it is
just right now the second thing I want
to talk about major win for this thing
are the speakers not a lot of reviewers
like to talk about this but not
everybody wants to wear headphones or
earpods you can just sit there lay there
watch a movie with somebody else and the
new six speaker system in here is great
it's a big upgrade compared to Old
MacBooks and Windows laptops it is not
as good as a 16 inch that's a lot
thicker but most people will be
absolutely floored with it now above in
that Notch we have a 1080p webcam but of
course you don't have to settle for this
you can use my favorite webcam the 4kc
one which I told you about last month
and I'm Still Loving It this thing is
built like a tank and the image quality
difference is massive even in perfect
lighting but in realistic the cases it's
mind-blowing even compared to using the
best iPhone which also requires your
phone to be locked up their software is
easy to use but very powerful and you
can use it with multiple devices thanks
to opal for sponsoring this video check
it out using the link below or watch my
full review video for more details as
for number three I need to talk about
the performance now yes we have the same
M2 Chip that came out a year before this
laptop in the 13 inch but in the 15 inch
model it performs better now the first
reason is because the graphics are
unbanned if you buy the 15 inch and
second because the chassis is larger
even though it does throttle it
throttles less so so you get about six
percent more performance but for
long-term use the throttle difference is
even bigger because the full heat soap
that you can get with the 13 inch after
about a half hour this laptop doesn't
really get there to that point now we we
made a full comparison against the
14-inch MacBook Pro and in a lot of
cases the laptop's performance were very
similar and I would argue that for most
people that are looking for a laptop the
performance is going to be way better
than their previous one and they will
not care whatsoever so unless you're
doing some massive tough tests that are
super long maxing out the CPU and GPU
which in those cases a 14 inch MacBook
Pro can be a lot more powerful this
thing is incredible and good enough even
for our uses now that leads me into
number four as far as pros and that is
the battery life everyone knows that
Apple silicon gets great battery life
and the 15 inch has a slightly larger
battery than the 13 inch but I compared
it to my previous Intel MacBook Pro that
is similar in size and even though the
battery is much smaller when we are
pushing the machines the 15 inch air
lasted for six hours compared to two and
that's pushing them hard now for simple
use you get 15 hours of real world
battery life which is incredible and I
know a lot of people will be upgrading
to a 15 inch from an older Intel model
but what I didn't mention in that video
is the low power mode that you can use
that brings down the total Peak wattage
from about 23 or so down to seven and a
half and a lot of times you're running
at about three watts and this will bring
up your battery life up to 22 hours
compared to 15 hours and I can use the
low power mode most of the time because
of how fast this works you don't really
feel it being slow which is absolutely
crazy for those that care about battery
life and for positive number five we
need to talk about the price tag because
Apple surprised us when they said that
you can buy one of these for 2
12.99 I was expecting 14.99 because
they've never sold a large screen laptop
at these price points you've always had
to spend way more money on a MacBook Pro
now of course with that price tag you
get eight gigs of RAM and you get a SSD
that is half the speed of the 512 model
and so even though the price tag is a
positive at that low end I have to go
into the negatives with the first one
also being the price tag because if you
upgrade this to 16 gigs of RAM and 512
and that is when the performance really
starts to scream and it's an absolutely
amazing laptop well then you are getting
close to a 14 inch MacBook Pro and
that's the way that Apple likes to do
things they want you to have this little
step ladder where you kind of want to
upgrade a little bit and then that point
you might as well spend a little bit
more money now with that the 14 inch M1
Pros are also available for about 1400
refurbished so we actually did a video
on that and and well it is hard to beat
that kind of value if you don't care
about the design the slimness and the
really great battery life and that is
already getting into number two which is
the value at Seventeen hundred dollars
equipped like this that's a lot of money
for a laptop and going back to the
original kind of question what went
wrong why is Apple having poor sales
half of what they expected well it's
because they are still sticking to that
8 gig 256 gig as base now those ssds
barely cost Apple anything it would
literally cost them five to ten dollars
to give you 512 as at a base the ram is
also not expensive and I feel like if
they would have gave us a bump up in
either one of those the sales would be a
lot better now issue number three and
you guys could see how these issues
aren't really really related with the
laptop itself but that is the M3 chip a
lot of people are waiting for three
nanometer chips and now we have
confirmation that production is going on
we're gonna see a launch in October
November time and people have commented
just saying hey I'm gonna wait for the
three nanometer chip because with a
three nanometer chip the M3 and a laptop
like this those thermal limitations will
pretty much be gone and the performance
will also go up at the same time so this
thing being released about a year after
the M2 Chip came out well it's kind of
right there in the Middle where some
people are like you know what I'll wait
a little bit for that other people just
don't want to buy a product that is
going to be replaced in a way with you
know better performance better battery
life less throttling very shortly so you
guys let me know does that matter to you
guys that much down in the comment
section below and if you thought about
buying one of these and you didn't you
were part of that 50 percent uh less
purchasers getting one why you decided
to do that now to wrap all of this up I
want to say that I absolutely love this
machine but in a lot of ways it doesn't
make sense because in the low end it's a
great price but you have limitations and
when you upgrade it well Apple itself
has a lot of competition with a lot of
great upgrades to this laptop if you
don't mind a larger or heavier design
with that said I have a full comparison
right over there for you guys to watch
see all of the differences in the real
world go and check it out but if you
don't need the best of the best in terms
of specs and performance I would highly
recommend it this has been Max and I'll
see you in the next one
[Music]
foreign